powerful messages from people in
Sacramento California obviously we're
seeing protests pop up around the
country but California making some
pretty strong statements that we're
gonna bring in California GOP
congressmen Devin Nunez now congressman
welcome to the show
what is your reaction to hearing some of
those comments from the protesters in
California well look I think it's going
to get a lot worse because the governor
that we have here is picking winners and
losers on a daily basis we've been
talking about this several for several
weeks now where some beaches are open
other beaches or not and I'll tell you
what what happened yesterday is I went
to Costco which I like to do the lines
were longer than I've seen lines at
Disneyland I stood in the line for 30
minutes to get my food there were
hundreds and hundreds of my fellow
Californians there and I'm all for
Costco being open when I finally got to
the checkout counter I had picked up
some lamb and chicken but then I was
told I could only buy three packages so
I sent the chicken back stood with the
lamb but you know not that the viewers
want to know what I had for dinner last
night but but I just I just think this
is ludicrous so the governor now is
treating different counties counties
that have voted to say hey we're going
to open up they're being punished I
talked to a couple of our local city
council and elected officials yesterday
and they told told me that they're being
intimidated by the governor and his
staff now to me that's extortion you
can't use federal and state tax dollars
where you disagree with someone's
policies or politics and punish them and
remember this is when neighboring
counties are are wide open the
restaurants are open so this is becoming
it's getting worse and worse and worse
and I think it's very very frustrating
for a lot of folks here in California
well congressman talk about frustrating
we want to bring in Ryan Driscoll a
performer on the cruise ship Seaborn
Odyssey Ryan good morning to you I
understand you are stuck on that ship
for some 80 days during the pandemic is
that correct that's correct it was
crazy time in congressman Nunez helped
bring you home explained yes I'm very
thankful to congressman Nunez and his
office they all helped me get home
quicker and safer they were putting
pressure on the local bridge town and
Barbados government and working with the
US State Department as well as the US
Embassy in Bridgetown to arrange a
charter flight to bring back American
citizens and I was one of those lucky
Americans that got to come home on that
flight what's what would it have been
like if you had not had a congressman
able to weigh in for you thankfully the
congressman took special interest in the
case but could you otherwise still be
stuck I think without congressman Nunez
and his amazing staff in California I
would not be here right now
in sunny San Diego I would still be
stuck on that ship like many many my
friends are still stuck on ships around
the world so very thankful to be back
congressman what hasn't meant for you to
be able to help bring Ryan home well you
know what's 100 the really only good
parts left about this job is you know a
lot of times we're the last line when
people get to us were their last hope
and we've had a lot of people in Ryan's
case all the members of Congress all
over the country have had had similar
situations but Ryan's was particularly
important because it took so long and
I'm actually thankful that he did get
back and I wish he would have got back a
lot sooner to be with his family back
here in California but we still have
some people still still overseas trapped
overseas who who can't get home so we're
still working on those cases speaking of
cases I know this is not related to the
cruise ship but any updates on the
investigations going on in Washington as
far as what happened to the Trump
campaign well if you're looking at what
judge Sullivan is doing I think this is
really out of left field I saw I heard
you talking to Doug Collins from Georgia
earlier in this in the program this is a
very odd case I think most Americans sit
there and look and say wait a second is
it this a federal judge been on the
bench for a really long time why would
he possibly need a lawyer he has to
understand the law he should be able to
to respond to his fellow judges that are
evaluating this case yeah it's really
unprecedented to see someone take it
upon themselves to to be the judge jury
and prosecution yeah being that the
Justice Department has dropped the
charges so we're continuing to to
monitor I'm one of the things we're
working on is looking at the Moller
investigation and everything surrounding
the Moller investigation because we are
looking to make criminal referrals based
on what occurred during that mold the
Moller prosecution's got it well Ryan
we're glad you're back enjoy sunny San
Diego hope you can go to the beach
eventually and congressman we love what
you have to say I would have skipped the
lamb and gone with the chicken though I
just I disagree with that
well some lucky family got those
chickens appreciate it thank you